they've stopped counting the covert dead
in north yemen
in a country battered by six years of
civil war
coronavirus is just another killer
[Music]
for those who've survived this far
there's a terrible fear of the virus
but also the hospitals and what will
happen to them
we asked mansour what he thought when he
was brought in
what did i do wrong why am i tied to the
bed like this
i can't breathe i have to get out what
did i do
yemen is uniquely vulnerable to the
covert pandemic
its population is already weak its
medical facilities shattered
nearly a quarter of the country's
districts have no doctors
at all so even young women like kalima
who's only 19 are hit badly by the virus
like so many yemenis she didn't think
coronavirus could be worse than the war
or the starvation they're already facing
she was wrong
[Music]
it's been very painful she says we've
been in so much pain because of this war
now this illness has devastated me
i don't know if i have the strength to
go on
in the absence of official data figures
collected by local medical staff show
a shockingly high number of health
workers have died with coronavirus
symptoms
any loss of any medic here is a tragedy
this hospital in the rebel
houthi-controlled area of sana
is entirely funded by foreign aid aid
which looks set to end
in the next month we are an emergency
situation already
during these factors the war and
conflict and mobility and literacy and
and
sober added the kobe outbreak
it's tough we hope we hope to er
another organization to help us we hope
to
send a message for the world to stop the
war stop the conflict
and help the yemeni to
through negotiation and peace
most of them are working without
salaries now and terrified about the
next few weeks and months
i don't want to to think in the future
because it
will be like a nightmare
i try to avoid thinking uh what will be
the next because we don't have doctors
more doctors
in the crowded alleyways of sana's old
city though we saw
few if any taking precautions against
the deadly disease
there seems to be a distinct denial
about the pandemic
absolute chaos here in this market
no social distancing whatsoever and i
think we are the only people who are
wearing masks
how does it reach everywhere else in the
world and not
yemen
have you ever thought about wearing a
mask
many of those who chew and get high on
cat leaves
believe the addictive plant has kept
them corona
but after years under siege by a
saudi-led coalition backed by britain
and america
the yemenis are deeply suspicious about
the pandemic's origins
with far too many believing it's a viral
attack on them by the west
okay
foreign
yemen's suffering has just got more
acute because of the pandemic
alex crawford sky news in sana